mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
solve for the value of n in the
following equation
the limit as x approaches zero
of one over x
multiplied by the natural log of the
following fraction
the numerator is equal to e to the power
of x
plus e to the power of 2x
plus e to the power of 3x and so on
until the final term of e to the power
of n multiplied by x
the denominator is equal to n
the entire limit is equal to nine
what value of n satisfies this equation
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
i had a lot of fun solving this problem
because it involves so many concepts
to get started we will rewrite the
fraction of the natural log in terms of
an inline fraction
we will then take the natural log as the
numerator and x as the denominator
we now have the limit of a quotient
to see this limit we will separately
analyze the numerator and the
denominator
we will then look at the behavior of
each of these functions as x approaches
zero
to do that we'll directly substitute x
is equal to zero
the denominator becomes zero
we will now simplify the numerator
n multiplied by zero is equal to zero
then e to the power of zero is equal to
one
there are exactly n terms so this sum is
equal to n
we then have n divided by n which is
equal to one
the natural log of one is then equal to
zero
so the function in the numerator
approaches zero as x goes to zero and
the function in the denominator also
approaches zero as x goes to zero
so we have zero over zero which is an
indeterminate form
therefore to calculate this limit we
will use l'hopital's rule
to do that we'll take separately the
derivative of the function in the
numerator and the derivative of the
function in the denominator
the derivative of x is equal to one
we can then just simplify this instead
of having a fraction i'll just make this
one term vanish
so we now want the derivative of this
natural log function
to do that let me just compress this
argument
from here we will use the quotient rule
of the natural logarithm to get we have
the natural log of the sum of these
exponentials minus the natural log of n
we can then take the derivative of each
of these separately
now the derivative with respect to x of
the natural log of n is equal to zero
so this term again will vanish
we now want to take the derivative of
the natural log of something
so we'll use the chain rule
it'll be equal to d u over u so we have
the derivative of the argument all over
the argument
we can then take the derivative of each
of these exponential functions
the derivative of e to the x is equal to
e to the power of x
the derivative with respect to x of e to
the power of 2x is equal to 2 times e to
the power of 2x
and the final term derivative of e to
the power of n multiplied by x with
respect to x is equal to n multiplied by
e to the power of n times x
from here we will consider the behavior
of each of these functions as x goes to
zero
we'll directly substitute in
then e to the power of 0 is equal to 1
then n multiplied by 1 is equal to n
we then want to calculate the sum in the
numerator this is the sum of the numbers
from 1 to n which is a well-known
formula for triangular numbers
t n is equal to n multiplied by the
quantity n plus 1 all over 2.
we'll substitute that in
the denominator will have exactly n
terms each term equal to one so this sum
will be equal to n
we then want to simplify this
now the n terms will cancel
so we have n plus one all over two and
that's equal to 9.
from here we just need to solve for n
we multiply both sides of the equation
by 2
2 multiplied by 9 is equal to 18
we then subtract 1 from both sides of
the equation so n is equal to 18 minus 1
which is equal to 17 and that's the
answer
what a beautiful problem involving
limits
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you